des cimetières plein dans tout le pays
ici à sao paulo les familles endeuillées
ne cesse d'enterrer leurs morts pour le
seul mois d'avril le pays déplore cent
mille morts dus qu'aux vide 19
et encore ces chiffres serait
sous-évalué selon de nombreux experts
pourtant aucune annonce de confinement
longue durée à l'horizon de la part du
gouvernement
par conséquent la ville et ses métros
sont toujours bondée j'ai peur et nous
sommes tous très inquiet j'essaie
d'éviter de sortir les gens ont besoin
de se déplacer pour manger quelle serait
la bonne solution
ils devraient tous fermés pendant deux
mois pour voir si les cas diminue mais
il continue de le faire tous les quinze
jours c'est inutile ça ne marchera pas
et avec ces nouveaux variants qui
arrivent ici ça va être pire
malgré l'urgence la vaccination peine à
s'accélérer la campagne a débuté mi
janvier avec les vaccins astrazeneca et
couronna vac jeudi soir un million de
doses spyder sont arrivés dans les pays
mais pour le vaccin rue spoutnik v
attendu par de nombreux états pour
accélérer le mouvement
l'homologation est toujours en débat une
lenteur dont le brésil se serait bien
passé tant le gouvernement est déjà la
cible de critiques internes en raison
d'une stratégie sanitaire qui suscite
l'incompréhension mardi au sénat une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire a été
mise en place
objectif déterminer la responsabilité de
l'état et notamment celles déjà erbol
sun araw qui ne semble pas déstabilisée
ya les responsables et ceux qui sont
coupables d'action d'omission de
négligence ou d'incompétence et si cela
est prouvé ils seront tenus pour
responsables
ce sera la réponse pour nous reconnecter
avec la planète les crimes contre
l'humanité n'expire jamais et son
transnationaux je ne suis pas inquiet au
sujet de cette enquête
je ne suis pas inquiet parce que nous ne
sommes redevables de
bien mais la situation politique demeure
sous tension
d'autant que dans l'hémisphère sud
l'entrée dans l'hiver approche et fait
craindre une diffusion accrue du virus à
laquelle s'ajoute la multiplication des
variants avec quatre cent mille morts
pour 212 millions d'habitants le brésil
est le deuxième pays le plus endeuillé
au monde après les états unis